all right so we've been talking a bit
about the tech component this grand
cultural war that's going on I you guys
quill that you're you're a small company
or you're funded on patreon which we're
funded on patreon it's pretty awesome
you have people that voluntarily pay you
to support your content yes you grow I
know how validating and rewarding it is
and all that stuff but you find yourself
often up against the big boys right like
that's funded to hundreds of millions of
dollars by different things and you're
being critical of them here yeah so it
does get me back to something that I
started with before about where does it
come from for you to just be brave I
don't want to I don't want to belittle
that part of it that there's a new
internet developing and I think it is
people that are doing this sort of thing
it's not these well-funded well-oiled
machines that were watching them crumble
you know I just you sent me this morning
this thing about boxes a drive is off by
15% or something and it's like we've got
slim trim companies and I think I really
believe that's the future economically
of this yep as well as in terms of
protecting the ideas yeah so we a pretty
we have a pretty amazing story we I
started by myself and I ran the website
for maybe a year or even a year and a
half before I got my assistant editor on
board who's now sort of the managing
editor and he's extraordinarily talented
extremely hard-working so I'm very
indebted to him for all that Jonathan
Jonathan hey and my other editor jaimé
okay jaimé more yeah okay yeah let's
give credit where credit yeah yeah and
um and my contributors are also amazing
but we are hit now as of 2020 18
September we're getting up to 1 million
unique visitors a month with a staff of
all part-time staff of 6 or 6 or 7
people and we're getting almost a
million uniques a month I am aware of
magazines that have a budget of millions
of dollars
that cannot compete with our traffic and
who have staffs of stuff like staffing
capacity of 30 40 50 people so we're
extremely lean but we're hard-working
and we're nimble and innovative like I'm
very I'm always thinking about
innovations to the business model what
can we do that's different I think just
following in the footsteps of the old
model is probably a recipe for failure
and I truly believe that advertising is
on the way out I know people can still
make some money through advertising but
I think out of it advertising gives you
a vulnerability because now you see
these activists trying to like target
brands if their brand is next to some
content that activists don't like so I
think advertising is just I think it's
Vaughn there's a vulnerability
associated with it and is it almost a
fake vulnerability though because I
always think when you know they always
try to boycott Hannity for example and
it's like all of the people trying to
boycott him and putting aside whatever
he said on that given instance they
don't watch him in the first place and
yet the advertisers still feel that they
have to bow to the mob and I always find
that to be a strange thing like there's
very few people who like Hannity who are
so shocked by something he said that
they want a boycott it it's always
people who hate him in the first place
that don't watch so there's an odd piece
of this that's like slightly
disconnected from reality I think well
corporations and companies in general
are skittish and conservative and they
want to protect their reputations and
they've they're afraid of any kind of
controversy and I agree with you that
these activists on social media who are
targeting companies they're a tiny tiny
minority of the population most people
don't care or buy into this stuff but
corporations is it's probably some PR
person who's like whoa we don't want any
controversy let's detach ourselves but
you know it that kind of
timidity and lack of strength and lack
of spine is not something that is part
of Colette so we very much conscious of
if we ever get mobbed and we do get
mobbed sometimes we don't apologize we
don't we don't we don't give in to the
hecklers veto basically yeah and I
really think it's important for
corporations company leaders anyone in a
latest leadership position to grow a
spine in the era of social media and to
not take any of this outrage seriously
yeah yeah not take it seriously or not
take it I mean I think we've sort of we
have to take it seriously because it is
sort of infecting a lot of society but
maybe not take it as if it's necessarily
right just because it's outrage is that
fair yeah you can say the recent example
an editor of the New York Review of
Books in Burma was fired because he
published an article by Canadian radio
journalist who was credibly accused of
many cases of sexual assault and I think
the radio journalist was like he's a bad
dude but the editor was sacked for
publishing his article within like the
space of two days or something so there
was a social media outrage phenomenon
and it's all wrapped up with me too and
then he's just fired just like that and
it's like okay take some time out to
consider it like listen to the feedback
from your readers or from people on
social media but when did we start
making decisions so suddenly these
important decisions that affect people's
livelihoods that's what I find
astonishing that people in leadership
positions just sort of throw all caution
to the wind and just say okay we're
going to SAP someone because some people
on Twitter are unhappy yeah and also the
guilt by association part
right I mean it's it's possible for a
slim trim operation that you have you
might find out in 10 years you might
find out that one of the guys you're
working with now three years ago did
something awful and then they'll use
that to try to tar you and yeah the
danger in that or that you sat down with
somebody and now we can put out a chart
that links that person to this person to
that person we're in an age of the
internet within six steps you can link
anybody to Kevin Bacon or Barack Obama
it's like it's pretty ridiculous yeah
look guilt by association is manitto
fallacy but it is powerful and we we do
find ourselves tainted and it's tricky
and I think we have to every situation
we have to judge on a case-by-case basis
and and you're probably right it
probably is going to happen but I I
trust my readers and I feel like they
know who we are
they know they're aware of our values
and they can make the appropriate
judgments at the time yeah so all right
so even though we've spent most of the
time here and most of the things that
you guys are writing talking about
what's sort of going on with the modern
left yeah frustrations that everyone
knows that I have like these guys yeah
let's talk about the parts of the right
that that you actually find scary or
untoward or whatever you want to call it
what do you think the alt-right is at
this point like if someone says you give
me the definition of alright what does
that even mean to you at this point well
I consider them to be the white
nationalists that that one in if ethno
state and they're pretty morally
repugnant and they're pretty scary and
they're engaged in some in quite vicious
trolling they send death threats the
journalist Kathy young for example was
one of the first people to write an
article criticizing the bigotry of the
yatra and she had death threat called
into her home and they're they're pretty
scary but I think they're a small group
yeah how are we able to quantify
because that's one of the things that
like I think people are just very
confused that they're making it seem the
media makes it seem because they call
everyone alright or far right yeah
there's this massive group I can only
talk about this in an American lens but
maybe it's a little different but that
there's this massive group of white
nationalists who are coming for to turn
America into some sort of ethnos state
now I'm not saying there aren't racists
of course there are racists and of
course there are bad people and people
using these tactics but I believe it's
just a tiny sliver and then and then on
top of that you have all sort of the me
makers and the [ __ ] posters and the rest
yeah yeah those guys you may not like
what they do but they're not there
they're having fun in their eyes in ways
they're not just the evil racist yeah
yeah yeah
I think a mistake was made back when
Milo was around and I think he you
started using the term all right and he
might not have been aware of where that
term originated and actually originated
with the white nationalists and so you
think you think Milo was using it more
in the way that I just laid it out or
just sort of these [ __ ] posting memes
yeah yeah I'm thing look without
acknowledging the other piece I don't
know if he was aware of where the term
originated or not but it was a huge
error error for people who are adjusting
to shitposting it was a huge area of
error for them to use that label for
themselves because unless you're what in
my view unless you are a white
nationalist you're not on you not a
nought writer I mean they had they the
label I think came about in 2007 and
they I think it was Richard Spencer who
created the Albright journal or
something so it was a big mistake for
people who just want to have fun online
and who want to you know just like push
back against some of these PC
orthodoxies it was a huge mistake for
them to use the term for themselves and
that's given license now for critics to
apply the term on everybody who pushes
back against PC dogmas
and that's really unfortunate yeah but
you know we have to just say it over and
over again like these people are
repugnant and we don't want to have
anything to do with their ideology the
ideal is all ideologies authoritarian
it's racist
it's um and and they engage in very
scary vicious behaviors yeah so
absolutely I will cosign all of that yes
for the record of course this is a
repugnant ideology and these people are
racist yeah the things so I'm less
concerned about that because I do
believe it's a small sliver that doesn't
have real institutional power now maybe
that's going to gain some and I think
there's evidence that at least in
Eastern Europe but some of these ideas
partly as a pushback to the immigration
problems that maybe it is gaining some
power but are you concerned that it has
a bigger institutional power because I
think the stuff that we're often talking
about is because we're worried about
institutional power yeah and structural
power not just that there are mean and
bad people out there which yes there are
Mena bad people out there and there will
always be mean and bad people out there
yeah because my background is so
recently in academia I focused a lot on
universities and the ideologies that are
popular within university so that makes
me focus on left-wing ideologies such as
critical theory post structuralism and
and Marxism if I was in a different
context I might focus more on right-wing
ideologies and the effect that they have
on institutions and I'm sure so you're
given a little knowledge of the post
modernist there because you're showing
that your own bias is a little part of
how you look at things yeah yeah
absolutely yeah yeah I'm sure if I was
closer to institutions that have more of
a right-wing ideological influence I
would be criticizing that more
criticizing those influences more yeah
being Australian is
in Australia our our conservative or
right-wing ideologies are quite
different to America so you probably
already know this but we have universal
healthcare
we have gun control we have a welfare
state so if I lived in a country where
we didn't have those things I would
probably be advocating for those right
but you know a lot of this is context
specific and you criticize what you know
so a part of the reason why I criticize
the what Jordan Peterson calls
postmodern near Marxism is because I've
experienced it I see it all of the time
enacted in academic settings and I worry
about the impact that that ideology is
having on media the law and just the
broader culture yeah are you hopeful
that some of the good ideas that we've
talked about here are going to win out
that seems to be one of the biggest
questions I get at public events now
like I think there is a sense that we've
woken up a certain amount of people you
know this Petersen Tours selling out
every theater thousands and thousands of
people really all over the world will be
in February in Australia in February
yeah um but I think there's still a
concern of like how much worse can yeah
before it gets better
yeah and that's the question people ask
me as well and I the I mean I don't have
an Oracle I can't see the future and all
I can say is that I'm doing my very best
to counter these bad ideas and that it's
it's actually anybody who's concerned I
mean they have some responsibility and I
think everybody should think about
sharing the risk so you know when
Charlie you need these people truly yeah
you know when Charlie Hebdo happened and
the mainstream media in Europe and the
UK and America I think didn't want to
publish that cartoon of Mohammed which
got those men and women killed Douglas
Murray came out and
do it [ __ ] the Reis that's when I came
where yeah it's one of his best moments
it's incredible it's on YouTube yeah
that was a something that impacted me a
lot as well and you know I anyone who's
concerned about the way our culture
broader Western culture is headed needs
to think deeply about how they can make
a little bit of difference by sharing
the risk just speaking honestly in
conversations with friends speaking
honestly and openly in the workplace
normalizing conversations and yeah just
just taking on a little bit of risk yeah
what does that tell you about the slide
that has occurred in the West is this
just a is it an infection of success or
something that we could be so successful
that even taking a little risk seems
awful to people humans are very
conformist and most people are cowards
unfortunately and a lot of what we're
talking about these bad ideas that are
being promoted only promoted by a tiny
tiny minority of people but they're very
noisy loud and aggressive and the
problem is simply the silent majority
not being feeling too intimidated to
sort of push back and if we can
encourage those who are in the silent
majority to push back against ideologues
on both sides both the hard right and
the hard left I think will create a much
healthier civil society yeah but it's
about empowering the moderates to speak
freely speak openly and and and not feel
afraid
like ashamed of their moderate views
right they've also turned words like
civility and moderation are thought of
as bad now you're a fence sitter you you
don't want to murder half the people you
know you're not Thanos from Avengers you
look beautiful
yeah I mean the Larry's people the
people who argue that civility is easy
bad thing and we see a lot of this now
by the way that civility is a bad thing
a lot of think pieces about this well I
would argue that some unrepresentative
of the broader population I know that
media and certain parts of media and
universities have been captured by
cultists in a way and they have these
crazy ideas but I would be careful about
generalizing those ideas to the broader
population because I think most normal
people are pretty chill yeah I mean I've
been enough time in your country to - no
no I think you are right I mean I'm out
there going across the country realizing
that there are so many just decent yeah
people yeah the hysterics in the way
that I said earlier about how social
media has leaked into reality or
something yeah it's making everyone feel
crazy but I am meeting these incredible
people all over the country yeah they
just want to live and let live and yeah
maybe I don't know your feelings on
abortion for example maybe we agree
maybe we don't it just seems that
actually seems irrelevant not a moment
yeah that sort of says something we
touched on briefly right before we
started that politics I was saying how
I'm not that interested in politics per
se at the moment even though this is all
framed within a political lens and I'm
much more interested in culture yeah is
that how you feel about this and is that
always how you felt about this or has
something shifted definitely I've never
been particularly interested in partisan
politics
but I think that politics is downstream
of culture so the ideas that are popular
within a culture then get reflected in
your politics so if you want politics to
be a certain way and to be a bit
healthier and less dysfunctional you
want to impact the culture first because
culture is bigger than politics yeah is
there a danger that we're just in this
like locked culture war now so that our
politics can never get better like we
sort of have this affair authoritarian
leftism and now we've got Trump
these are the cultural fights that we're
having now there's a couple of us in
this spot right but like that if all
politics is going to come for
those two things at the moment that
politics sort of is almost irreparable
damaged yeah look I don't know what the
future holds for the United States from
an outsider looking in it it does look
quite scary
the theory level of tribalism that's
that seems apparent just the and the
amount of hate and distrust that each
side has for the other it's quite scary
I just hope that if the worst happens to
the United States we will always have we
will have outposts where Western
civilization through survives and
thrives New Zealand Australia so
basically going back to what I said at
the beginning it's good to be surrounded
by water yeah yeah we'll be we'll be an
outpost yeah yeah we're gonna need that
much yeah yeah yeah a lot of people are
going to New Zealand and buying houses
there in case the worst happens oh god I
don't want to end on this terrible over
here wait we've got to bring this back
but all right so there's concern about
that
of course like right if you want to go
down that rabbit hole you could look at
all of these ideas that I truly think
are the ideas that could unravel Western
society and free thought and all those
things that's why I talk about them so
much yeah
but there is a counter and then that's
what we got to keep doing so the brain
can bring me home on a positive note
please before people start buying real
estate and you doing or you were just
trying to help the market in Australia
there no no we don't need any help
in the housing market we I'm optimistic
because I see the amount the positive
reception that I get through Collette
our audience grows every month more and
more people are contributing to our
website feeling brave enough to write
their thoughts down and send it through
and the thing is every individual has
the power to change the world of ideas
if you've got an idea and you can
articulate it and write it down and send
it in or articulate it on in in some
other fashion you do have the power to
transform
and impact this this culture and to make
a huge difference so that's that's
incredible and that makes me feel happy
and optimistic all right that is how we
can end it we can't end it on the
seasteading we're gonna make water world
kind of thing
for more on Claire's work check out
Qualcomm and they are also on patreon
[Music]